okay so let's have a look at this
diagram how did we make this thing okay
I hope as you saw this diagram your mind
went straight to the overall you like oh
yeah we made one of these this is how we
walked through we actually created it
okay so the first thing I want you to
remember is um if you have a look at
those vertical numbers right down the
middle
0:15 what are these numbers represent
okay so there are differences involved
right for example you can see the
difference from here to here is 15 the
dishes from the difference rather from
here to here is 20 okay those numbers
are going to be really important in my
diagram as you can see but where they
come from is where you you're literally
counting those ticks right you can't you
can't you can't and that's why the
number keeps on getting bigger and
bigger and bigger what you want to do is
look at as City suggested look at the
differences between those numbers can
you see where the differences are on my
diagram have a look
the differences are here there's the
first one 15 10 5 and 20 so you can you
see me walking up the field or across
the field rather and be realizing okay
this is how much further I've gone how
much further I've gone how much row you
can see as well where the other numbers
come in the numbers on the sides what do
they represent again yeah very good see
when you see that that 30 on the left
that means you're like okay from that
spot I walked over that way and I just
called that e I just gave it a name okay
and in the same way I'm with 2127 yes
okay to the right and that's what gives
me this sum this interesting diagram
okay
so once you've got the right links there
you had to recognize that you've got 4
triangles 1 2 3 4 and then you've got
this guy over here which is a trapezium
so you can see I actually gave names you
can see those are my names over there
and that's how I calculated the area
okay does anyone want to ask any
clarifying questions
I